my second is on the sheet gun case you
guys want to stick toward the water this
time actually this is much better lit it
looks like
enemy drone is Clark I should be a look
at their drone I'm on your right
theory
kinda want to get on top of this
building that's where everybody usually
goes though
now I'm gonna move up here so menu items
over here on the stairs one more uh sir
I'm watching to your right no Matt up
here I see one of your teammates
tracking and enemy troll
I see you I see their sniper Connor I
got eyes on her body
snipers down
where's that I'm going to fire out one
of those sensor dark things
since your oh my god sensor not
employing the sensor
I see someone right right on pink
another sniper right here on pink I
should be able to get her if she peeks
out is that tonight they're still sniper
up top here
that circles coming into the building
where they were though I see one down
I want to stick over this way this time
just darker stay out of the light this
time
don't see anybody a surveillance system
has just been located
movin up theory
doesn't railing system is ready for
hacking I see someone right on paying I
think is that a person one of your
teammates is injured I see him he's
moving right here I'm working an enemy
there might be another one over there
I don't anybody know where he is
if it's one person I'm gonna go for the
surveillance system yeah
actually theory right here figure right
over here I'm gonna go south again yeah
that's coming toward us fury put your
own nice thank you
someone's sniping right up there like
right on pink I don't know if anybody
can see yeah they've got pretty good
angle on us period
I can get the drone yeah they might know
where I am now after that your own did
you saw where I paying with a sniper you
know where from
over it where are we I was shooting I
see you this snipers got a really good
angle on me I'm coming
Mary hey I'm coming I'm gonna go back to
the south after this wait did I hit not
heal you
one of your teammates is injured
somebody get me a medic tracking and her
own I'm gonna move up on the south there
kind of a theory I'm gonna move up over
on like it this way
yeah I'm gonna move up toward them
there's a few items over here oh I see
someone right here I don't know he's
alone or not okay they know where I am
now I'm gonna watch this body
I'm just gonna watch this body in case
they've been pretty much reviving
everybody I'm also right near
surveillance
I'm watching Fury's body might be able
get surveillance
yeah Furi Furi you're going for it yeah
oh my god he's over he's next to me
nice I'm just I'm just gonna rush over
it he's the last one I'm right above him
that's Hill
[Music]